you ever notice I'm on the cover of like
every x-men poster Wolverine is always
like like he always has his claws like
right next to his eyes or his throat or
something and I'm like dude be careful
you're gonna kill yourself away he can
heal that's why he's a badass he doesn't
care
x-men Days of Future past is directed
once again by Bryan Singer returning
after directing x-men 1 and 2 and then
going off to direct Superman Returns
instead of x-men 3 this movie stars
everyone if you're a fan of the x-men
franchise you've got Hugh Jackman
Patrick Stewart Ian McKellen as well as
the cast from first class you got James
McAvoy Michael Fassbender Jennifer
Lawrence all these people combined to
tell a time-bending futuristic story in
which the future x-men are being taken
out by the Sentinels which were created
by Trask
they send Wolverine back in time to the
70s try to make Charles and Eric become
friends again so they can unite then to
eliminate the Sentinels before they're
ever created time-travel movies can go
both ways because you can watch a time
travel movie and just pick it apart as
you find various plot holes and
inconsistencies because time travel does
that to every movie ever but at the same
time it gives the writers and the
director a chance to do something that
you're not expecting because they
literally can pull anything out of the
bag because they're going all over the
place with this story does it feel
cohesive though as a story are there too
many characters are they all jumbled and
running around can you not latch on to
the characters can you not feel for them
because there's too many no x-men Days
of Future past might just be the best
x-men movie we've ever had listen to me
okay I'm not gonna be a fanboy during
this review despite the fact that I want
to because I grew up with the x-men
franchise I'm kind of close hearted to
that franchise because after the Batman
ended with Batman and Robin people were
wondering if superhero films were going
to be around anymore x-men came out in
2000 and proved that this is still a
genre that people care about and can be
made awesomely and Bryan Singer has
returned to fix all the problems that
have been around since his departure
x-men Days of Future past actually
validates x-men 3 and x-men origins it
takes all the mistakes that were made in
those films and corrects them it's great
I love this movie now I want to
about the awesome action sequences and
the extremely clever humor that is
throughout this movie but I really
really want to focus on the fact that
the emotional core of this film is so
intact and it starts so fast - like
you're just in it from scene one you are
in this dark war of the future and then
instantly it's like okay we gotta get
Wolverine back there's no breathing room
in this movie it just starts and you're
there no as I said the movie does have a
really good sense of humor - it's not
all like oh it's the war and rold
approach and world those characters make
jokes and they work and it doesn't feel
like somebody's just writing jokes to be
funny all the characters that do funny
things are all because of who they are
as a character I gotta mention
Quicksilver in this film every scene
that Quicksilver is in there's not a
whole bunch but every scene he's in in
fact there's a scene in this movie
involving Quicksilver I'm not gonna
spoil it but it involves him
demonstrating his powers without a doubt
one of the best scenes I have ever seen
in a comic book film in my life that one
scene is worth the price of a ticket
alone I guarantee it it is incredible
it's so good I'm not gonna spoil it for
you I will talk about it in my spoiler
review though see a lot of people tend
to bash these big blockbusters because
all the special effects and kids love
them this movie has on display
incredible acting talent Patrick Stewart
and Ian McKellen are fantastic in their
roles but honestly the big standouts of
this film are James McAvoy and Michael
Fassbender and Jennifer Lawrence as
mystique we know Hugh Jackman is awesome
as Wolverine and he is once again
fantastic in this movie very funny
totally badass
and you really felt like he was that
x-men 1 & 2 Wolverine you know he just
had that in him but seriously James
McAvoy in this film is brilliant and
Michael Fassbender is equally brilliant
and to watch those two actors they have
such good chemistry as one another but
you can just feel like endless amounts
of backstory have already taken place
within these characters and that's one
of the best ways to present compelling
characters in a film is when you're
watching them you feel like these people
have been places already like they exist
in a real world and x-men Days of Future
past
solidifies that for nearly every major
character in this film yes there are so
many characters in this film and it's
very easy to mess that up we've seen
that recently in a superhero film in
my opinion amazing spider-man to handle
his characters terribly this film is
able to take these characters have them
all be related to one central story arc
and it makes it all work the action in
the film is relentless it's extremely
well filmed very well choreographed
there's a terrific scene involving
mystique in which a person in the 70s
captures what's happening on a really
like four by three terrible quality
camera and when we see some of that play
back in the middle of the scene it added
this intense realism that almost felt
like we were watching some horrific
thing on the news Jennifer Lawrence is
so badass in this movie as mystique but
her character also has that great
emotional pull every single one of these
characters that has those really awesome
fight scenes and cool comic book moments
all have emotional arcs in this film
that you are able to latch on to that
all work as the film wraps up at the end
and as I said this film makes x-men
three-count it actually makes some of
the more shitty aspects of other x-men
movies better Peter Dinklage in the film
provides my only issue with the movie
and not him as an actor he's actually
excellent in this movies a very very
good actor it's his character I didn't
really feel his motive for hating
mutants so much and wanting to create
the Sentinels which is kind of important
since the Sentinels are the big thing in
the movie that we're not supposed to
like but I'm able to accept that because
it didn't really detract that much from
my enjoyment of the movie I'm gonna give
x-men Days of Future past and a I think
it is an excellent comic book film
filled with emotional characters you're
able to care about and incredibly
awesome action scenes it might just be
the best x-men film we've had also I
just got to say hearing John Ottman
score his theme the x-men theme in a
movie again fantastic so guys when you
do see the film or if you have seen it
I'm interested in knowing what your
thoughts are on it what is your favorite
x-men film let me know below and as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck nice